until we find a way to integrate
Humanity into the kind of sustainable
flow of the Earth's Rhythm and Cadence
we're doomed right but it's an
opportunity and I think that if you look
at nature nature is never in a hurry and
yet everything always gets done on time
right and we have to figure out a way
for us as a collective to do the same
for ourselves and you know that's not
the way that at least Western Society is
constructed but I think that we are in a
very interesting time where people are
becoming really excited about new
modalities for living I mean we see the
explosion of wellness and the way that
people are thinking about how they take
care of themselves and we're at an
inflection point on the planet where we
really do have to shoulder the
responsibility for not just our own
individual wants and needs and desires
but those of the whole